there are a lot of questions i find
myself pondering with a last generation
television some things like what if i
could control it with this i've asked
myself things that i didn't really think
i could answer like what if i could
watch two tv channels side by side with
some sort of picture in picture at the
same time google tv became available and
i finally realized that what i've been
thinking about actually finally exists
see i don't really watch tv all that
often but when i do i usually know
exactly what i want to watch and when
i'm going to watch it the majority of
the content i actually view is on
youtube
yeah on those smaller screens back there
but what if i want to watch youtube on a
bigger screen what if i want to be able
to google the stats and announcers
talking about as he announces them what
if i want to check up on twitter and my
ad replies during a commercial break
what if i want to use some of the same
apps i love on my phone on a huge screen
well luckily that's all possible with
google tv which is really cool and
that's exactly what i'd be doing with it
if i had one my name is marcus brownlee
from mkbhd and this is my last minute
video entry into the gtv contest thanks
for hosting and thanks for watching
peace